le rugby maintenant avec un véritable
effet coupe du monde pour les enfants en
tout cas ils sont beaucoup plus nombreux
cette rentrée à vouloir s'inscrire dans
un club c'est notamment le cas à
suresnes près de paris où le rugby est
une tradition même si on est loin du sud
ouest et il faut dire que pour les
enfants c'est un sport qui permet de se
défouler autant que dans une cour de
récré julien pas cette vincent vous
fatigue séjour d'inscription au club de
suresnes il y a du monde beaucoup de
monde ce club de la région parisienne a
réquisitionné ces éducateurs pour
accueillir pas moins de 140 enfants qui
vont jouer pour la première fois au
rugby avant de toucher le ballon on
ainsi sur la philosophie du jeu
je voulais demander de tailleur devant
regrouper
c'est une notion essentielle vous allez
voir les matières d'échauffement faudra
toujours courir ensemble
la notion de solidarité
c'est une des notions importantes pour
ce sport
ces sportifs en herbe ont entre 6 et 11
ans en une après-midi ils doivent
apprendre les rudiments du jeu passer le
ballon plaqué éviter l'adversaire le
rugby plaît aux enfants qui retrouvent
dans ce sport un peu les jeux de la cour
de récré des poules sur le devant du
sport des xive et qui forestia faut
rester en groupe
d'accord politique en art et en plus ça
rebondit partout sim plein dans leur
guise et c'est quand on marche dsr ouf
ou quand on place les gens les parents
sont venus nombreux ils n'ont pas eu
vraiment choir que sont leurs enfants
qui les ont amenés sur le terrain au
rugby c'est un peu l'esprit des animaux
fallait quand même motivé beaucoup plus
rublee que foot est bon je pense que le
contexte des coupes du monde doit a dit
aussi sur son chemin il ya une
coopération une aide rapports réels
physique avec les autres
le club ne pourra pas garder tous les
participants à une journée d'initiation
faute de place preuve de l'engouement
autour du rugby avant la coupe du monde
le nombre de licenciés chez les jeunes a
augmenté de 10%